one of the things that you can do but
there's an important caveat
to increase your sense of meaning in
life is to get into the flow state more
frequently that's why i said you you
want a moving practice that's conducive
to the flow state but there's one
important
caveat
which is
we of course have figured out and i'm
playing with words here how to game this
and how to hijack it by creating things
like video games i'm not saying this is
the case for all video games or this is
the case for all people but the who now
acknowledges this as a real thing that
you can get into the flow state within
the video game world
to the detriment of your ability to get
into the flow state in the real world
what's the opposite of flow
depression
fact depression has been called
anti-flow
so you get these people they're flowing
in this
non-real world
and it's
they can't transfer it to the real world
and it's actually costing them flow in
the real world so they tend to get they
tend to suffer depression and all kinds
of things oh your ability your uh habit
and just skill at attaining flow in the
video game world
basically
makes you less
effective or maybe shocks you at how
difficult it is to achieve flow in the
physical world yeah i'm not sure about
the idea i just i don't i don't want to
push back against the implied
challenge of transferability
because um
you know there's a lot of you know i
have a lot of friends that play video
games a lot a very large percent of
young folks play video games and
i'm
hesitant to build up models
uh of how that affects behavior my
intuition is weak there oftentimes
people that have phds are of a certain
age that they came up when video games
weren't a deep part of their life
development i would venture to say
people who have
developed their brain
with video games being a part a large
part of that world
are in some sense different humans
and it's possible that they can transfer
more effectively some of the lessons
um
some of the ability to attain flow from
the virtual world to the physical world
they're also more i would venture to say
resilient to the negative effects
of for example social media or
or video games they have
that you know maybe the objectification
or like the over sexualized or violent
aspect of video games they're able to
turn that off when they go to the
physical world and turn it back on when
they're playing the video games probably
more effectively than
um
the the old-timers so i just want to say
sort of
i'm not sure it's a really interesting
question how transferable the flow state
is
i don't know if there's if you want to
comment on it i do i do um first of all
i did qualify and i'm saying it's not
all the case for all video games or for
all people i'm holding out the
possibility and i know this possibility
because i i've had students who actually
suffer from this and have done work
uh around it with me um the the ability
to digest they couldn't they couldn't
transfer yeah
um and then they were able to step back
from that and then take up the cognitive
science and write about it and work on
it um
also
i'm not so sure about the resiliency
claim because
um
there seems to be
mounting evidence it's not
consensus
but it's certainly not regarded as
fringe
that the increase in social media is
being is pretty strongly correlated with
increase in depression self-destructive
behavior uh things like this i would
like to see that evidence because
no no no no i i
let me um
i'm always hesitant
to to eagerly kind of agree with things
that i want to agree with that there's a
public perception everyone seems to hate
on social media
i i
i wonder as always with these things
does it reveal
depression or does it create depression
sure this is always the question it's
like
uh whenever you talk about any political
or ideological movement does it create
hate
or does it reveal hate and that's a good
thing to ask and you should always
challenge the things that you
intuitively want to believe i agree with
that um
like aliens
so one of the ways you address this and
it's not it's not sufficient and i did
say that work is preliminary but you you
if if i can give you a plausible
mechanism uh that's new
and then that lends credence and part of
what happens right is illusory social
comparison
uh think of instagram people are posting
things that are not accurate
representation of their life or life
events in fact they will stage things
but we what the people that are looking
at these right they take it often as
real and so they get downward social
comparison uh and this is a and and this
is like
compared to how you and i probably live
we may get one or two of those events a
week
they're getting them moment by moment
and so it's a plausible mechanism that
why it might be driving people into a
more depressed state so okay the flip
side of that
is because there's a greater greater gap
going from real world to instagram world
you start to be able to laugh at it and
realize that it's artificial so for
example even just artificial filters
people start to realize like yeah
there's like
it's the same kind of gap as there is
between the video game world and the
real world in the video game world you
can do all kinds of wild things
uh grand theft auto you can shoot people
up you can do whatever the heck you want
in the real world you can't and you
start to develop
an understanding of how to have fun in
in the virtual world and in the physical
world and i think it's just a push back
i'm not saying either it's true though
yeah those are very interesting claims
the more ridiculously out of touch
instagram becomes
the easier you can laugh it off
potentially in terms of the effect it
has on your side so i'll respond to that
yeah but at some point we should get
back to flow
as we engage in flow you laugh at the
hair the shampoo commercial
you buy the shampoo
yeah there's a capacity for tremendous
bullshitting because of the way these
machines are designed to trigger
salience without triggering reflective
truth seeking
i'm thinking of counter examples uh
because you're
sometimes you're
uh can laugh all the way to the bank so
you could you can laugh and not buy the
shampoo right there's there's many cases
so i think you have to laugh hard enough
you do have to laugh hard enough but
the advertising the advertisers get
millions of dollars precisely because
for many many people it does make you
buy the shampoo and that's the concern
and maybe the machine of social media is
such that optimizes the shampoo buying
yes the point i was trying to make is
whether or not that particular example
is you know
ultimately right the possibility of
transfer
failure is a real thing
um and i want to contrast that to an
experience i had when i was in grad
school and i've been doing tai chi choi
about
three or four years very religiously in
both senses of the word like three or
four hours a day and like reading all
the literature and like
i was having all the weird experiences
you know cold as ice hot as lava all
that stuff and
right
but my friends in grad school
they said to me
what's what what's what's going on
you're different
and i said what do you mean
and they said
well you're a lot more balanced in your
interactions and you're a lot more
flowing and you're a lot more sort of
flexible and you adjust more and i
realized oh
you know and this was this was the sort
of taoist claim around tai chi chuan
that
it actually transfers
in ways that
you might not expect you start to be
able and i've now noticed that i now
notice how how i'm doing tai chi even in
this interaction and how it can
facilitate and afford and so there's a
powerful transfer and that's what i
meant by you know flow wisely not only
flow in a way that's right making sure
that you're
distinguishing causation from
correlation which flow can do
but
find how to situate it home it so that
it will percolate through your psyche
and permeate through many domains of
your life
you